para poder terminar el diseño de su
nueva montaña rusa danielle debe
resolver esta ecuación tenemos la
ecuación 7 que multiplica x 39 igual a 5
el complete el problema como se ve en
los pasos siguientes y aquí están los
pasos que efectúa daniel entonces
después dice su asistente revise sus
cálculos y le dice que la respuesta es x
igual a menos 1 en que pasó cometió
danielle un error veamos o que vamos a
revisar lo que daniel hizo aquí tenemos
la ecuación original 7 que multiplica x
+ 3 - 9 igual a 5 vemos que en el paso 1
daniel se deshace de este 9 entonces que
hizo daniel para deshacerse de ese 9
pues no simplemente sumó de a ambos
lados de la ecuación 9 así que de este
lado suman 9 y también del lado derecho
suman 9 entonces aquí estos 29 se van a
cancelar
y obtiene 7 que multiplica x 3 igual a
14 porque 59 es igual a 14 después ya
que tiene esto en el paso 2 lo que
danielle hace es multiplicar 7 por 14
eso es igual a 98 entonces lo voy a
poner en notación de un punto para
denotar que multiplicamos 7 por 14
eso es igual a 98 pero aquí al parecer
daniel olvidó que lo que haga de un lado
de la ecuación también debe hacerlo del
otro lado de la ecuación cierto entonces
aquí daniel no multiplicó 7 por 7 aquí
debería estar un 49 pero no lo está
porque daniel cometió un error aquí
simplemente multiplicó el lado derecho
por 7 pero olvidó multiplicar el lado
izquierdo por 7 después lo queda en
enlace es deshacerse de este 3 en el
paso 3 lo que daniela sias deshacerse de
ese 3 entonces va a restar del lado
izquierdo 3 y también del lado derecho
resta 3 estos dos se cancelan y le queda
x igual a 98 menos 3 es 95 x igual a 95
pero la respuesta tenía que ser x igual
a menos 1 y donde daniel cometió el
error fue en el paso 2